bien mes chers amis et bien moi je suis
heureux d'être là heureux d'être là
depuis depuis hier rue joie que
supporter seuls merci alors je sais pas
si un jeudi soir vous étiez devant vos
écrans de téléviseurs écran de
télévision
moi j'y étais j'ai vu notre président de
la république et je pense qu'on a
assisté jeudi soir à la plus mauvaise
intervention de françois hollande depuis
qu'il est président de la république on
est passé du monsieur petites blagues
sert alors enfin gus à monsieur petites
combines et alors on peut prendre les
sujets les uns après les autres
vous savez notre dame notre dame des
landes avec la quand même quelque chose
assez exceptionnelle c'est à dire
décider d'un référendum sur une décision
qui a déjà été prise qui a été annoncé
par le premier ministre et qui est purgé
de tous les recours
un référendum sur des bases juridiques
d'ailleurs tout à fait discutable et sur
un périmètre incertain on est dans le
françois hollande telle qu'on l'ait mme
c'est à dire je suis votre chef
donc je vous suis
ça ne s'arrête pas là la révision
constitutionnelle il découvre que c'est
une procédure qui peut être longue
c'est dommage qu'ils ne voulaient pas
demandé on lui aurait dit et puis il
nous annonce aussi que ma foi il l'a
annoncé mais s'il faut y renoncer il est
prêt et renoncer quant au remaniement
avec françois hollande on est passé d'un
françois hollande qui incarnait la
faiblesse politique à la médiocrité
politicienne écouter ce numéro avec les
verts ces distributions ces définitions
de postes ministériels dont on
n'imaginait même pas les titres et puis
sur les sujets économiques
rien sur les sujets économiques il y a
quelques semaines souvenez vous ce n'est
pas vieux il nous annonçait qu'il allait
déverrouiller les 35 heures
déverrouiller les 35 heures mais sans
toucher à la durée légale pas bien
compliqué ou encore il nous a annoncé
qu'il allait avancer sur la dégressivité
des indemnités chômage mais sans toucher
ni aux montants ni à la durée
là aussi ça devient compliqué vous savez
c'est un peu comme quand on on demande
un collégien de nous faire une une
dissertation sur une boule de billard
sans parler ni de sa couleur dit sa
forme 10 de ce à quoi elle sert peut
toujours y arriver mais j'avoue que pour
donner un cap à son gouvernement c'est
quand même pas facile alors faudrait
revenir aussi d'un mot sur la la
déchéance de nationalité
cette mesure nous l'avons réclamé
je ne suis pas certain et vous m'avez
entendu le dire à plusieurs reprises
qu'il fallait passer par la révision
constitutionnelle mais le gouvernement
est maître de l'ordre du jour de nos
assemblées
c'est lui qui en décide et au cas où
certains ne lancerait pas convaincu nous
ne sommes pas au gouvernement
donc c'est bien le gouvernement qui
décide et donc nous nous devons nous
positionner sur un ordre du jour
qui a été décidé par le gouvernement et
à partir de là on avait deux solutions
soit on décide d'enterrer définitivement
cette mesure que nous avions réclamé
depuis plusieurs années si nous avions
voté contre c'est ça en prenait la
décision que cette mesure ne verrait
jamais le jour
soit nous continuons sur notre logique
et nous l'envoyons au sénat monsieur le
président pour faire en sorte qu'elle
soit réécrit conformément à nos souhaits
parfait au sénat qu'à ma foi nous avons
là la chance d'y avoir la majorité
vous savez au lendemain des attentats de
charlie hebdo en janvier 2015
j'ai dit au nom de notre groupe
parlementaire avec bruno retailleau que
à chaque fois qu'il s'agirait d' armer
la france contre le terrorisme nous
saurions aux côtés du gouvernement et
nous serions rendez vous et nous n'avons
pas manquer un rendez vous à chaque fois
qu'il a fallu voter un texte qui
permettait d'assurer notre sécurité nous
l'avons voté avec responsabilité
alors maintenant si après la réécriture
du texte par nos collègues du sénat les
députés de gauche n'en veulent pas ce
sera leur responsabilité
nous nous aurons pris les nôtres en
attendant il ne s'agit pas parce que là
aussi on a tout entendu de dire que
cette mesure empêchera quelques dingue
de de commettre des attentats nous le
savons bien nous savons bien qu'on peut
imaginer tous les textes que nous
voulons lorsque nous sommes en face d'un
fou il n'y a rien ayew poser la question
n'est pas non plus de savoir si nous
allons oui ou non faire un cadeau
politique à françois hollande il s'agit
simplement d'affirmer une chose simple
lorsqu'un individu portent les armes
contre la france lorsqu'il tire contre
nos militaires contre nos gendarmes
contre nos policiers lorsqu'ils massacre
des innocents bataclan il n'est pas
digne d'être français c'est cela nous
voulons
et notre vote la semaine dernière du
groupe des républicains s'étaient la
cohérence avec cet engagement alors
cette décision bien entendu si elle est
portée au goût elle n'exonère en rien le
laxisme de la gauche sur d'autres
décisions qui auraient dû être prises et
que nous avons porté depuis plus d'un an
je pense au placement en résidence
surveillée des individus radicalisés
je pense à la fermeture de toutes les
mosquées salafistes
je pense à la condamnation de ceux qui
consultent ces sites internet qui
prônent la haine et la violence je pense
à la mise en place d'un système des
coudes dans nos prisons et encore
beaucoup d'autres mesures que nous avons
porté la gauche d'exonérer de rien elle
a pris un an de retard sur ses décisions
et nous le voyons bien à chaque fois
qu'il ya besoin de décider de trancher
nous sommes devant un président de la
république qui est dépassé par les
événements en face d'un premier ministre
qui lui ne reste en place que par la
force de nos institutions
parce que la réalité c'est qu'il n'a
aujourd'hui plus aucune majorité à
l'assemblée
et ce qui est vrai en matière de
sécurité l'est tout autant sur le plan
économique social ou fiscal
comment dans les ordres ces conditions
blâmer les français qui veulent
retourner la table ils ont compris
qu'ils n'ont plus rien à attendre de
cette gauche explosé démembré et disons
le nocifs pour notre pays
c'est donc à nous à nous de faire la
preuve de notre crédibilité de notre
détermination et de notre cohésion pour
sortir le pays de l'ornière
contrairement à la gauche nous avons un
vrai atout c'est globalement nous
n'avons pas entre nous de fractures
idéologiques
nous n'avons pas de fracture idéologique
donc ça n'est pas la peine
dalé s'inventer quelques faux débat pour
chercher à nous démarquer les uns les
autres sur fond de primaires pour
préparer l'alternance
les français attendent de nous que nous
jouions collectif avec à la fois rigueur
et détermination
je nie n'auront n'ignore rien des
primaires je fais partie de ceux qui
étaient plutôt poser mais la décision
nicolas dit tout à l'heure elle est
prise et maintenant il s'agit de la
mettre en application
je pense aussi que leur réussite n'est
pas directement proportionnel au nombre
de candidats qui prétendront à cette
primaire notre responsabilité c'est
celle de celle de notre famille
politique c'est d'alimenter le projet
politique
l'uclat l'a rappelé tout à l'heure mais
personne dans ce domaine ne part d'une
feuille blanche notamment sur les
blocages de notre économie sur des
sujets comme celui du temps de travail
la nécessité d'avoir des accords au sein
de l'entreprise désaccord sur des
accords majoritaires qui permettent
d'être à la fois lorsque le carnet de
commandes se remplit d'être offensif
c'est à dire de déclencher les heures
supplémentaires à partir de la 37ème la
39e ou de la 40e heures ou au contraire
des grands défensif lorsque le carnet de
commandes se vident
c'est une mesure je crois sur laquelle
nous pouvons nous rassemble est celle du
coût du travail avec la nécessité de
basculer une partie du financement
notre protection sociale sur la tva qui
nous permet aussi de financer notre
protection sociale par les produits
d'importation celle de la réforme sur
les retraites
là aussi nous savons qu'il faut
repousser l'âge vous savez c'est une est
une équation simple à trois entrées soit
on baisse les pensions soit on augmente
les cotisations soit on allonge la durée
de cotisation nous avons fait le choix
d'allonger la durée de cotisation et en
même temps de poser un calendrier qui
permet d'avoir un alignement du public
et du privé et de sortir aussi des
régimes spéciaux
comment aller expliquer aujourd'hui
qu'un conducteur de tgv peut prendre sa
retraite à 52 ans et qu'un ouvrier maçon
peut l'apprendre à 62
et bien je vous invite à les expliquer a
parlé de la pénibilité
si vous le souhaitez sur ce sujet même
chose sur l'apprentissage à 14 ans et la
fin du collège unique
si on ne revient pas sur le collège
unique l'apprentissage à 14 ans nous ne
le mettrons jamais en place il faut
avoir le courage d'assumer cette
décision sur la fonction publique
là aussi nous sommes d'accord pour
revenir la nécessité de revenir sur le
un sur deux mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi aller plus loin
lorsque l'on demande aujourd'hui aux
collectivités de se regrouper avec les
intercommunalités et qu'en même temps
parallèlement on leur dit on va
économiser les charges mais en fait on
créait plus d'emplois dans la fonction
publique en permanence est ce que
aujourd'hui il est logique lorsqu'on
s'engage dans la fonction publique comme
peintre comme maçon comme électricien
comme directeur des services techniques
il y a besoin d'être à la charge de la
collectivité territoriale pendant 60 ans
40 en activité 20 ans de retraite je ne
le pense pas je pense qu'on peut tout
simplement recrutés en cdi
hélas non plus qu'on n'explique pas que
le cdi c'est la précarité
voyez autant de sujets sur lesquels on
peut se rassembler et c'est donc une
véritable révolution idéologique qui
doit avoir lieu
il s'agit de replacer le travail au
coeur du pacte social et sur ces sujets
socio économique sur l'éducation mais
aussi sur la sécurité sur la justice sur
la nécessité de réorienter notre
politique étrangère
nous voyons bien que nous sommes
rassemblés important et pourtant un peu
plus d'un an de l'élection
présidentielle nous apparaissons trop
souvent comme divisé alors pour dire un
mot des des primaires moi je veux
demander à nos candidats ou à nos futurs
candidats puisque on a jusque jusque
septembre de prendre un peu de temps
dans leur intervention pour dire tout le
bien qu'ils peuvent penser du travail
qui est réalisé par nos groupes
parlementaires au parlement européen au
sénat à l'assemblée nationale dans les
conventions de notre mouvement qui sont
formidablement
ya organisé vous savez les français nous
aiment
lorsqu'on est unie et rassemblée ils
nous détestent pour pas dire qu ils nous
haïssent
lorsque nous sommes divisés alors on
peut certes passer tout notre temps
permanence à se critiquer les uns les
autres
on peut même en faire un job à plein
temps mais objectivement depuis un peu
plus d'un an
notre famille politique les comptes ont
été remis à léquilibre la primaire elle
est lancée et les financer après avoir
gagné les municipales en 2014
on a gagné les départementales on a
gagné les régionales on vient
d'organiser des élections internes qui
se sont formidablement bien passé alors
moi mes amis en votre nom à tous si vous
le permettez je voudrais féliciter
remercier encourager l'ensemble de notre
équipe dirigeante et notre président
qu'il anime avec conviction avec courage
avec le tempérament qu'on lui connaît
merci christian